You are listening to radiolab radio from
W. N. Y. S. T. E. N. N. P. R.
I thought we would begin by looking backwards at a,
at a wonderful moment in the history cinematically of parasites.
He's the cinematic history of parasites. Okay, so do you remember that movie?
I'm not going to tell you the name of it. Yeah. Starts out. In fact,
I have the script right here. Setting space.
[inaudible].
Okay. That just empty space
script continues.
The stars shine cold and remote like the love of God. Ooh,
you imagining this? Yes.
Now floating in that vast nothingness as a tiny dot of a ship.
You can barely see it. Hmm.
Cut to the interior of the ship.
Here we are in a ship full of astronauts who are tired and dirty.
Renee will tell you, look there, no
palling around and you just get the feeling.
This is a normal day in their astronauts lie until what they're on the computer
radar is a disturbance, some kind of distress.
CIC transmission out here. Yeah.
Do you think we got to check this out so they trace the signal,
eventually get into a pod and short,
and they find themselves at this abandoned ship.
[inaudible] totally abandoned second ghost ship.
I never seen anything like that. I knew what happened. The,
it's empty except for these weird eggs in the astronauts for like looking at the
eggs and touching the eggs and going,
oh,
okay. Now fast forward. We're back into the first ship. Okay.
Everything's fine for the most part,
and then something happens and I want you to,
I've got the computer there in front of you. Okay.
We'll push this push to space bar space bar.
All right, well you're at the table.
Everyone's dressed in white.
The first thing that I get to do when I get back is to get some decent food.
Indigo. I'm talking, chatting. They're all having like salad too. Yeah,
they're just eating. Talking. One of the guys gets a little weird, right? Oh,
he's not feeling so good. One of the guys. Oh no, he's coughing.
Coughing. Oh, don't tell me trouble breathing.
He's falling back onto the table. Chest is heaving. His wrist. Oh my God,
he's kicking his head wildly and he's like flexing all over the table and
something. He's like, Oh,
oh God.
So there's a red thing. I read the horrible sneaky thing. This is of course,
the classic scene from the original alien movie scene where
the little thing bursts out of the guy's chest and like hisses why did,
cause I think I figured out why that scene as scary. I mean,
when I first saw this movie, that scene went over and over and over in my mind,
and it's had this effect on a lot of people and I think I know why. What are,
you know, it's not that the little creature is disgusting, which it is.
It's that it was there all along. Sitting there. Yeah,
inside him, like incubating,
waiting to think that you sitting in that seat right there could have in your
gut these little worms that are wriggling around doing more or less what that
alien was doing. And I can't even see them in, you
can't even talk about it. So it's not,
today's subject on radio lab will be flowers. Even meadows coming up after this
[inaudible]
no, we're not doing that. We're doing, we're doing that an hour on parasites.
These little creatures that live inside us invisibly and yet can have a huge
influence over who we think we are. What is a parasite?
Precisely a moocher. And just to sort of slide us in, get us into the mood.
I'm already not in the mood. We thought we would get things started.
Maybe I'll just move this over here.
Well there really is no other way to start a show on parasites except with this
guy. You should introduce yourself. My name is Carl Zimmer.
Carl's a science writer and parasites have been on his radar ever since.
He was a little boy.
I grew up on a little farm and my mother would raise tomatoes sometimes in her
pensionable garden and uh,
sometimes there would be these caterpillars feeding on them and my mom would be
very annoyed and every now and then I would notice that some of them didn't look
very well and they had this little sort of fuzzy white bumps on them and I
didn't really know what they were. Well, it turned out that they had been, um,
attacked by a parasitic wasp,
which had laid its eggs inside of it.
Those eggs that hatched and had become larvae.
And those larvae were swimming around inside that Caterpillar while I was eating
my mother's tomatoes. And they were growing,
growing inside the Caterpillar. And then finally when they were ready, they,
they came out and only then did their host die.
And when he finally found out that that is what was happening inside those fuzzy
white bumps, profound situation,
this whole universe of a baby's growing into adolescence,
that's when I guess I sort of got very hooked,
which is probably an understatement because you are sort of like capital p
parasite man.
And if you look in the New York Times or science magazine or any of the places,
Carl writes,
a suspicious number of his articles are pretty flattering to parasites.
People have been dismissing parasites for a long time. Calling them degenerates.
No, I would argue that parasites are not degenerate.
They have gained the ability to live inside three, four, five,
six different species. Should you find that you sort of,
you're a lawyer for them. Hey Sir, you call this degenerate. How dare you, sir?
Say That I look,
I'm a defender of all on the collected and put upon species out there.
Why wouldn't a parasite the what?
I think you mean when you say degenerate because the title thing,
it infects something else. It sucks. Whatever. That it's not independent. Right?
So when you say it's not degenerate, what did y, what do you say that? Well,
let's start with saying it's not independent irony.
Any of us independent Kit Carson,
have you stripped all the bacteria out of Kit Carson?
Kit Carson would get very sick. Daniel Boone on the other hand,
now there's a guy in the panel alone in the woods. Daniel Boone eat,
I guess Daniel boot eats pigeon like the rest of us. What's your point, Carl?
In right point is the Daniel Boone eats meat. He ate bread,
which came from plants. Liz, the question of degrees though,
we're not living inside the intestinal track with some other creature,
so why does living inside seem like it's a degenerate thing as opposed to us?
Yeah. We can't even synthesize a lot of our own vitamins anymore.
Where the degenerates in a lot of ways, no car, no car.
If you are a creature that lives off someone else's vitality cheaters,
she would be another way of putting it. But listen, can you appreciate it?
I'm just gonna cut this short right here. Carl says, no, no, no.
There are amazing time and time again. He says, no, no, no.
The argument went on. Still waiting to hear about how you,
how you are able to photosynthesize your tell you to do it for me,
but I go about it in a mental way. You can't even do it yourself. Like I said,
the argument went on and on with Robert saying one thing and Carl firing back
and me adding another and here's what we're going to do just to be fair and
square about this. We're going to bring in an independent moderator.
Lolo yourself. Yeah. Com you're going to be the monitor. Yeah.
You get them like right. You're going to be the moderator and uh,
you listening right now. We will leave it to you,
your decision and this one lightning round. Go ahead. Shall I do that? Okay.
Yeah. [inaudible] parasites.
Are they evil or are they awesome? Starting with number one,
that a parasitic wasp,
there are probably 200,000 species of parasitic wasps out there.
Big Wasp, small wasp.
They're generally pretty tiny and they go after all sorts of things.
Some will lay them in columns. Caterpillars.
Spiders are the one Carl's going to tell us about this.
This particular wasp is called [inaudible]. Compressor goes after a cockroach.
[inaudible]
and for those of you who never thought you'd feel sorry for a coffee,
great.
Keep listening. So what it does is it [inaudible]
flies around and it looks for a cockroach.
And once it finds that [inaudible]
approach shit land and then
the fight begins, they tumbled back and forth around,
around until finally the wasps somehow manages to arch its back around the body
of the cockroach and uh, stings it
right in the belly. The cockroach twitches for a second
and then false. The cockroach is paralyzed. Now the wasp takes its time.
Repositions itself puts its button up right near the cockroaches head
and delivers a second sting.
The Stinger actually threads its way to a particular spot in the brain.
And this does something odd.
Moments later the cockroach recovers. Started, stands up. I can walk again,
but something is wrong. Very wrong. It just stands there
like a week. But the cat run away. Yeah.
Mu It has essentially lost its will. What does that mean? Uh, it's [inaudible].
Yes, it is a puppet. It's become a Zombie basically.
And so now the wasp will literally grab onto the cockroaches antenna and start
pulling on it. How does it grab with, what does it grant?
I believe with its mouth.
Imagine tiny wasp guiding a cockroach across the desert floor like a dog on a
lead and so it leads it down,
down, down, down into a little borough it's made and the cockroach says,
okay, whenever you want to go. Then
once the wasp has the Roach in the borough,
it lays its eggs on the underside of the cockroach to now you've got this
drugged roach sitting on top of some wasp bags and then the wasp goes out and it
seals the borough. It berries the cockroach alive. Well,
it's two minutes shell. It's in a little chamber.
It doesn't want to kill the cockroach because this cockroach is going to feed
its, you know it's young. Yeah, so then the eggs hatch
and then they drill inside the cockroach. You're still just sitting there.
How's it staying alive at this point? What parasites are very careful, you know,
they won't eat vital organs that will kill it. Instead,
Carl says they just feast on the extra stuff.
There's a lot of stuff inside of a cockroach,
a lot of fluid just floating around. It's of Wonderbread essence of skin,
old hair, and you can just feed on any, the host stays alive. Wow.
And then what happens?
Eventually the little baby wasp larva grows up inside the cockroach and develops
into an adult. And then one day the watch
eats its way up a little hole out of the,
out of the cockroaches body shakes off its wings and flies off,
and then the roach dies. Then the roach dies. Why? Normally then? Yeah.
[inaudible]
that to me sounds like of the purest description in nature of evil that I can
imagine. Wouldn't you agree? Well,
Darwin certainly said that God should not be personally blamed for having
created parasitic wasps.
[inaudible]
but if you ask Carl, he'll have you think about that moment,
the moment where the wasp stings,
that brain parasitic wasp can attack a cockroach and inserted Stinger into one
specific part of the cockroaches brain and inject a precise little cocktail of
drugs that then turns the cockroach into its slave.
I know that that was,
didn't get a phd in neurobiology and yet it has performed a kind of brain
surgery very precisely in a very elegant way. Uh,
or evil might be the other way. Okay, let's go. Go ahead.
But there is a complexity there that you can't deny
[inaudible]
or can you,
we leave it to you bringing us to example number two,
parasitic name to food. I mean, here's,
here's a another example that I actually was looking at today because you're
holding your computer up to the glass and on the screen is a big black and it
looks like it's carrying a cherry, right?
A Cherry that's about twice the size of the ant.
That Red Cherry is actually parasites inside of the aunt making it look like a
red cherry. What part of the aunt is that? Is that it's, but essentially, yeah.
Wait a second. Is it,
it looks like it's sticking its big red button up into the air. Yeah.
Their behavior is changed or they waggle around their, their,
their tail as it were. Nope.
Why on earth would a parasite turn on ants but red and then make it stick.
It's bought up into the air. Well,
let's say you put an ant down,
it has this bright red from your end and an ordinary and in front of a bird,
birds can go for that red and very quickly because it thinks it's a berry. Yeah.
And then what?
It's going to swallow this little package full of nematode eggs.
So that's the way the nematode eggs get into the sky.
They buy their airplane tickets by advertising themselves as berries. Yes.
What's the benefit of being in the air? Well, the,
the only place that this parasite can, uh, reproduce is inside the bird.
And how better to spread your seed far and wide than to drop from the sky
with the birch droppings. That is brilliant. That's brilliant.
I mean, look at the, that it's red. It's up in the air.
Yeah, it's amazing.
It's like how can a stupid little thing be so brilliant because they're not
degenerates, but they're still cheating.
And then just to bring this point home, just to pick a common one,
Carl offered up his third and final example. Number three,
blood flukes.
Blood flukes are related to flatworms tapeworms.
So their eggs start out in the water,
fresh water in Africa, Asia, parts of South America.
And the first part of their life,
they go into a snail and they come back out into the water and they're swimming
around and they start looking for a human.
So imagine a foot going into the shallow end of the pot.
I see toes, I see bottom of foot, I see ankle. Well,
if you're a blood fluke, you don't see anything. You don't advise. Oh sorry.
But eventually you find a foot, secrete a little enzyme,
basically turn a little bit of skin into butter. Wow.
And you slip into the vein and now
you're going to swim my circulatory system. Sure.
Which ones you're going to ride along in the blood.
And now it's time to find a mate, a mate.
So there's sex. So there's a male and female. So what you're saying? Sure.
They're animals. They're animals. I would have never called them animals.
It's interesting you say that. That's a whole nother topic I guess so.
All right, so we'll, the female is very thin,
each service standard issue where I'm kind of thing,
but the male is very strange. It's, it's Kinda like, like a canoe.
It's gotta be trough down the middle. Uh,
and at one end it's got a giant sucker.
Should we urge some of our listeners to tune away at this point because,
but it's about to happen. May Not be acceptable. And family, our, um,
actually blood flukes are, are fairly, uh, monogamous and loyal. So you know,
if you're looking for or for animals to reinforce your family values,
blood flukes pretty good.
And eventually two blood flukes find their way toward each other and the male
does this sort of court ship or whatever reason the female says, yes,
I accept your courtship. The female joins the male,
so fits in the trough. Oh, so it's like a groove.
The female goes and occupies the groove right now this isn't just,
this isn't mating. This is way beyond meeting.
The males will feed the female for starters.
And they will stay this way for a long, long time. Really? Yeah.
Like days, years, years, years. Yeah. Oh my God.
Years in human time. A years to them. Just years, years, years. Years. Years.
Like the earth going around the sun kind of years. Yes. In fact,
there've been cases where people show up at their, yeah,
the doctors feeling awful. The doctor does some tests and says, oh,
you've got blood flukes. No.
You had to have been in Africa to get this disease.
When have you been in Africa? And the person said 40 years ago,
44 zero 40 years ago. Yeah. And,
and the reason that they're getting sick is that these male and female blood
flukes are still together making eggs.
And Carl's literally glowing when he says this. I have to admit,
I do love the thought that, um,
parasites are among the most monogamous animals on the planet.
It's heaven. I mean, you're going to spend the rest of your life together.
And so our story concludes the image of two blood flukes in
your veins for nearly half a century.
Got handed to him. He's good, Carl, you mean? Yeah, yeah.
And there is a species of take farmers can be named after me. No kidding. Marie.
Yeah. Wow. It's not quite as much of an honors do you think?
At first I was talking with the Paris fetologist and she was telling her fellow
expert about how she was gonna name one for me and then they got into a
conversation about, you know,
that was good that you named that particular tape parm for him because he's
Kinda thin and it's kind of a thin day for him. You know, my aunt is, she's,
she's a little round and it's a kind of a round table and I named her after and
you suddenly discover there are a lot of tape wants to be named.
How many is a lot? I mean tens of thousands of species of tapeworms. Wow.
So they got us beat many times over.
I once a estimates that if you took all the viruses in the ocean and you stuck
them into to end, how far would it go? And, um,
it was many light years, way beyond our galactic neighborhood.
In other words there more cheats than there are honest people.
Honest creatures on earth. Oh yeah.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
which got to break things and I think we should.
Thanks to Lulu Miller and of course Carl Zimmer,
who has written many books including parasite rex,
a book we shamelessly parasitized for the making of the previous segment.
Also want to encourage you to go to our website where you can find pictures of
the uh, the blood fluke spooning the aunt with swollen red button
and of course the wasp with the cockroach nature porn and it's all yours.
It radiolab.org
[inaudible]
I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich. Stay with us.
Hi, this is Carl Zimmer.
Video lab is funded in part by the Alfred p phone foundation,
the corporation for public broadcasting and the National Science Foundation. Hi,
this is lily leaving you the credits on a land line.
Radiolab is produced by W NYC and distributed by national public radio.
Okay, bye. And this message,
this is Annie Schrader calling from Salmon, Idaho.
Radiolab is supported by Casper and award-winning manufacturer of one premium
mattress.
It's engineered for supportive comfort and ships in a compact box right to your
door with free shipping and returns with supportive memory foam,
Casper creates a sleep surface that contours to your body.
Casper gives you quality mattresses at a great price.
You can order online and try it in your own home risk-free for 100 nights.
Save $50 on your Casper mattress by visiting
casper.com/radiolab and using the offer code radio lab.
Hello, I'm Janna Boomerang and I'm Robert Krulwich, Radiolab. Our topic today,
parasite parasites.
Now we've met them there are nice and we've met them when they're not so nice.
I don't know that we've met any nice ones. Really are we having, I thought,
I thought that was pretty nice. Yeah, they were nice. So,
but now the question is, let's just talk about the scale. I mean,
for the most part they're irritating and Ludo and they seemed kind of invisible
and visible in sort of off stage. Yeah.
But when you back off a little bit and consider them, you know,
in the effects that they have on the world,
there are actually these powerful sculptors of monumental narrative.
In other words, these are little guys telling very big stories.
In fact, here's an example.
Recently I went to visit a guy named Dickson Despommier,
but Columbia University, he's eight. There's Telegist and well,
there's a bunch of different things and we ended up talking about, um, you know,
he told me this crazy story. The story I love telling the most. Oh,
and before we start, I just want to say one thing.
The following two stories contain moments that are a little bit gross.
Just want to make sure you've been warned.
The story I love telling the most is how we eradicated hookworm.
The story begins in 1908 John D Rockefeller,
Sr really rich guy's sitting in his New York office and he's thinking,
how can I make more money selling something to the south? Yeah,
I've got all this money. We've got all these resources.
I just need a new market. In terms of new markets.
The South was pretty much untapped
if only those damn southerners just get off their butts and get going.
Problem was they weren't, they weren't getting off their butts.
The forms were not operational. The economic engine was turned off.
The economy was in the toilet. And so John D Rockefeller wanted to know why,
why aren't they producing more? Yep. What's happened to their economic engine?
So he thought, I know all form of commission. Yeah.
So will you send out a bunch of economists and sociologists and people like that
on the original Rockefeller Commission? They did.
Every single commission could possibly do to try to find out why these southern
gentlemen were not rising to the occasion and they came back with the following
conclusion. Well, we, we don't exactly know what's wrong,
but we think that these people are sick from something cause they don't,
they don't behave like we do. What does that mean? They are slow?
Not Mentally. They're slow. Physically. They're Pale. I'll give you an example.
You remember the movie deliverance? Sure. Okay.
Remember that little guy that played the Banjo?
I remember the other scene that we all know,
we're not gonna talk about that and we're doing it. No, we're not.
But if I got mind you,
if you can recall what that little badge old player looked like,
Ooh, why are we looking guy? But he looked old sickly pants, sickly Pale,
and yet an adult. Well, Lena said wizard wasn't,
that is not a description of all southerners. No description.
One teeny corner in that. No.
But with the commission did say about a lot of these southern people they
encountered is that a lot of them may just don't look right.
They look weakly look when they look kind of [inaudible] one why they would want
hale lethargic. It's interesting [inaudible] or one one future.
So the thought was that maybe these southerners had some kind of laziness
disease. This is really what a lot of folks thought.
The one member on the committee suggested a Rockefeller like, you know what?
Perhaps
these people are anemic, anemic. They're, they're anemic to your say, yeah,
they're anemic. Sounds like a medical problem.
Then maybe they're not lazy after all.
Maybe they're anemic and maybe they're just weak. Next thing you know,
Rockefeller puts together another commission, this one with doctors,
and he sends them back down to the south to find out what the basis for the
anemia was. And not only did they find anemia,
but they found a correlation of the anemia was soil types. That's bizarre.
Sandy Loam, soils, anemia, hardpack clay soils. Hmm.
No anemia. Sandy loamy soils, good farmland, hardpack clay soils,
not such good farmland.
So all the rich farmers were anemic and all the poor farmers were doing okay.
And this seemed to be a clue.
The incidence of anemia was linked somehow to the soil.
Maybe bump a bum. Yeah, something was in the soil. That's correct.
So somehow they hit upon this idea of looking for Hook
[inaudible]
the hook one
this is that. All right, let's run some tests. And when they did, big time,
they discovered hookworm big time.
Okay.
So the anemia is due to hook.
Now the question became,
how are these southerners getting the hookworm and giving it to one another and
a pretty good place to start to look for an answer.
Was there a feces because of these hookworms are in you.
They're going to come out at you when you go to the bathroom.
So they asked these southerners, when you guys [inaudible],
where do you do it? Most of them said something like this, right?
I came over there. You see a tree over there? That's right, deprecate.
So I deprecate it over there, but I live over here. Okay,
so then the investigators ask the next question,
when you go to that tree and do it, do you, do you wear any shoes?
Most of them said no barefoot, just like everybody else. He goes,
it's comfortable.
So clearly these worms are in the feces that are landing near the tree that are
somehow getting into people's feet the next time they come to use the tree.
But no one intentionally steps in their own, you know,
no one does that, which meant,
oh my goodness, oh my goodness, it can crawl,
right? So let's find out how far it can crawl.
So what they did these researchers is they built a sandbox and then they took
some hookworm infested stool and put it right in the middle.
Then every day we'll sample from the stool sample out in the sand in all
directions and find larvae and find out how far they can travel.
How's that sound?
So now we have larvae in the stool and they begin to crawl away from the stool
seeking a victim. On Day one,
they crawled an entire foot in all directions, but they weren't a two feet.
On Day two, my God, they're at two feet.
At Day three they're in three feet. I can't believe it.
They're crawling all day four they crawl to four feet.
What about day five? No, I am allowed to ask that. And what about day five?
Five feet? No, no. Four feet.
That's it. So after four feet there,
what exhausted one would assume on day six there were still at four feet.
And on day seven they were dead.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
so how in the world could you deal with this problem when these worms can crawl,
they can crawl four feet. It doesn't matter where your difficult,
they're going to crawl away from that.
And within a four foot radius of that stool sample, you're going to get hookworm
unless you do something radical that's never been done before.
They devised a scheme for burying the stool sample into the ground six feet deep
because the worms can only make it four feet.
Well then that's two feet past the point where they die. We call that the owl.
So the outhouse was invented by exploring the life cycle of hookworm and in
fact, Rockefeller got his wish the south did rise again.
That sounds too easy to me though. You're telling me that that uh,
an understanding of Hookworm, which created the outhouse, removed the quote,
southern laziness disease and they did rise with the, and you,
you bring that all back to the hookworm. I do. Really, I,
I'd bring it back to sanitation now to be fair,
you can find plenty of other reasons why the south rose again,
air conditioning and highways and university, right, and stuff like that.
So the oak room had some help.
But what is clear is that when we as a country began to distance ourselves from
our own excrement, to put it bluntly, when we stop walking around in our own,
there were all of these unintended concepts.
Salmonella disappeared is the Lyrica disappeared, Shigella disappeared,
cholera disappeared. GRD had disappeared.
Cryptosporidium anything that's associated with parasites in feces disappeared.
Every time we built out houses and people use them religiously,
guess what?
Their kids can stay in school. They could learn more. They got ahead faster.
[inaudible]
Dixon,
this momma is a professor of public health and Environmental Health Sciences and
Microbiology at Columbia University.
Can they make longer titles at that university? He literally wrote [inaudible]
the book on parasites. The book is called Parasitic Diseases.
You know it very well and seemed to be a major motion picture. You know,
it's fourth edition in its fourth edition.
And while we're on the subject of hookworms and the glorious campaign to Deworm
America,
because this has been a very carefully crafted and intentionally fair program,
you have heard the case against hookworms.
Now let's turn the coin and say something nice about hookworms.
And to begin that discussion, let's go to our reporter Patrick Walters. Okay.
So Pat, are you there? Are you there? Yeah, I'm here. Robert.
So tell us a little bit about this fellow. What's his name exactly?
His name is Jasper Lawrence, right? Jasper Lawrence. So where's he from?
He actually grew up in England and he grew up in this little farm in the
southwest corner of England. And it's important to know,
I think before hearing any part of his story that Jasper has had allergies for
pretty much his whole life
on really bad days.
My eyes would swell up so much from Poland or airborne allergens that they would
feel like there was swelling shut. I could feel my eyes squeaking in my sockets.
It was an enormously uncomfortable feeling, but it was nothing debilitating.
They were just allergies. And so, you know, he's just like,
like most other people have allergies. Just learn to deal with it, you know,
you live with it.
But what changed for me in my late twenties early thirties was my asthma.
And in that time I was living in Santa Cruz. I was relatively recently married.
We had three cats that had been grandfathered in with the relationship.
And I started a landscaping business. I really didn't want to work for this.
I think someone with allergies starting a landscaping business that seems kind
of unexpected, unexpected stupid is actually the word for it.
And uh, within six months or a year,
he starts to notice this really weird barking cough.
Was there anything particular that brought this on? Like, no,
it was just sitting and breathing. Um, cat certainly didn't help. Right. And uh,
during that period my asthma got much worse very, very quickly.
By the time it was 1996, 1997,
I was seeing specialists having skin allergen tests and cycling through
emergency inhalers,
trying Singulair and all these other drugs that were coming on the market.
I was being hospitalized, um, at least a couple of times a year. I mean, I,
I looked terrible, had dark eyes and Pale, waxy skin.
I had that allergic look. It was a really bad time.
And he decides in that summer of 2004 to take a vacation,
he made this visit to England. Yeah.
I took my two daughters back to see my aunt who had raised me very early in the
visit. I was sitting at her kitchen table and she asked me if I'd seen a BBC
documentary about parasites in their connection with things like asthma and
allergies and multiple sclerosis, and of course I hadn't,
but I went upstairs and got on the Internet
after lunch and I stayed on the Internet until perhaps two in the morning.
I did.
I was reading and reading and the work of all these researchers have been steady
after the neck in Japan and epidemiological studies and African animal models of
multiple sclerosis. This enormous weight
of evidence that in the developing world,
people don't really have asthma or allergies.
And what he discovers is that behind all of this,
to his shock is
hookworms hookworm. Yeah. Hookworms yeah.
I learned that asthma was 50% less likely in someone who had a hookworm
infections. So this sort of just like hits you. Oh yeah.
What'd you think when you, when you read that?
Oh, immediately was determined to obtain hookworm immediately. I couldn't wait.
So hookworms are these very tiny worms,
the size of a little hair.
But if you take a microscope and you zoom way in,
they have this big circular mouth brimming full of pointy teeth.
Very scary to look at.
They have these toothy mouths so that they can burrow up through your feet,
Grad through your blood,
and eventually end up down in your gut and start chewing on the inside of your
intestine. This guy wants hookworms in his intestines. Absolutely.
And so you, you just Google it. Yeah. Hook Hook Worms
for sale. I mean, you know, someone's got to be selling them, but not nothing.
I contacted every laboratory supply company in the world and Paris etology
research centers and they all said the same thing.
No various flavors of no.
And so I came to the conclusion that I was going to have to go to the tropics.
So fast forward a little jasper is in Cameroon along the coast,
quite literally and figuratively.
The armpit of Africa is 200 miles north of the equator. It's extremely hot.
He finds a guy to drive him around and so he and his driver would go to a
village. You'd get out of the car,
walk up to these villagers and ask them if they could see the latrine.
Just an open area of ground,
usually with bushes so people can have a little bit of privacy and I would go
over to the area, remove my shoes and start walking.
The first time I did that, I uh, I almost couldn't do it.
It was, it must've been 110 degrees that day. 100% humidity
and the stench and the noise from the insects,
it was so repulsive and so disgusting.
How many villages of the trains do you think you've visited? Between 30 and 40.
Jasper spent two weeks there walking around in the village,
latrines and then he flew home.
Yeah, I got back from Africa in early February.
So I was looking at allergy season coming up and the day I realized that I no
longer had allergies. I was such a good day.
I got into my car and I started driving and I had the window down and I felt the
breeze blowing across my face in the past.
What that meant was that very quickly my eyes would be itching uncontrollably,
snot and phlegm was going to be pouring out of every orifice in my face and it
didn't happen.
It didn't happen. I just started screaming in the car.
I was so, so happy
and I haven't had an asthma attack since I went to Africa.
I no longer have allergies.
The vast majority of the benefits that I've experienced has come from hookworm.
Yep.
What, what is the hookworm doing, do you know? Well,
so the immune system that we learned about in elementary school is all about
like these attacks, cells that go after foreign invaders and destroy them.
Right. And that's a big important part of the immune system.
But if the immune system were allowed to attack and destroy things unchecked,
it could kill you.
And there are lots of diseases where the primary symptoms are caused by the
immune system attacking the body that it's really designed to protect.
Allergies and asthma are just two of these.
Some of the more serious ones are like type one diabetes, multiple sclerosis,
Crohn's disease in which the immune system actually starts attacking the inside
of the intestines. They're like 80 FDA's disease, 80 of them.
And so what scientists have found in lots and lots of mouse studies and in some
human studies to this point too,
is that once the hookworms get inside the gut and the immune system actually
starts attacking,
somehow hookworms actually stimulate these cells,
which just quiet things down
and tell the attack cells to stop attacking.
So these are like lullaby sells Zackly what lots and lots of scientists think
Joel Weinstock,
Tufts Medical Center and dozens of others is that over thousands and thousands
of years hookworms almost developed in tandem with the human immune system
co-evolution parasites living within your body, your immune system changes.
You've got to a point where the hookworms could survive safely.
Worm gets a home,
there's food coming down the food pipe and in return the human immune system
gain some kind of some form of positive regulatory advantage.
[inaudible]
so that if you had this glitch where your immune systems started attacking your
own body, the presence of the hookworms would keep things controlled.
That's the gift. You do something for the worm. The worm does something for you.
So then by that logic,
what we in the West and the richer countries have done stupidly is we have
cleaned ourselves up too much and we don't have enough worm EEZ in us. Yeah.
This is called, they call it the hygiene hypothesis,
the hygiene IPOs that we are not dirty enough to clean.
We function like rainforests where ecosystems and we've entirely eliminated a
class of organism that co-evolved with us and or genetic predecessors for
millions of years.
Now, I don't want to leave the impression that hygiene is bad for you.
People can't go back to living in filth,
kids playing and sewage by the river bank. But in improving our hygiene,
we are also excluding organisms that may be important for making a swell.
So then what does Jasper do about all this?
He decides to start a business selling hookworm to people.
What you can call him up and he will literally FedEx a dose of hookworms to your
door. How side? Raking for a second, Pat.
I Jad where does he get the hook and from, this is weird.
Jasper gets the hookworm from himself.
Could you describe how you go about getting hookworm from,
uh, your stool into, uh, one of your patients?
Well, that's um, very easy organism to work with it, it just,
it gets up when it walks out of it so it doesn't take an enormous amount of work
to separate it from the feces. And then I haven't done that.
I repeatedly wash them in solutions of antibiotics to make sure that,
and I think that could live on them is killed. People contact us,
we'll have them complete a questionnaire, submit a recent blood test,
then we'll ship them a dose and all the materials and equipment and the
instructions necessary to inflict themselves.
Twitches does this the safe thing to do? Jasper?
Jasper has done tons and tons of research, but he's not a doctor.
The treatment is not approved by the FDA in general.
I wonder is there any serious sort of double blind study trying to figure out
whether some safe delivery of hookworm might make sense? Yes.
And so one of the guys who
was sort of a pioneer in this hookworm room research is David Pritchard.
I'm professor David [inaudible] ologist in Paris,
otologist of the University of Nottingham where I study parasites and the wound
healing properties of maggots.
So we've now got two safety trials and drive belts,
but we've yet to conduct the trials to show that therapeutic benefit results
from infection with words.
So Prichard infected himself pretty much just to make sure that it was safe.
What we did was 10 of us in the lab took worms at different doses.
We were either given 10 25 50 or a hundred worms and then we had to report on
the symptoms along the back of that study,
we determined the 10 wounds were tolerated. But Richard,
when he did this proof of safety study actually gave himself 50 hookworms. Oh.
Which put him out of commission for Awhile. I felt pretty bad.
I mean pain in the gut really,
you know you can feel them cause they are biting on your tissues.
I mean if you have too many hookworms they can cause things like diarrhea and
the most serious side effects and the side effect that makes them a sort of a
public health enemy is that they can give you an emia.
So if you have too many years
you lose quite a bit of blood to these parasites. Well you know,
if you take too many hookworm which are not going to, if you come to us,
the worst thing you're going to get is anemia.
But it's not like you wake up one morning and you're drained to blow,
very slow to develop and it's very easy to deal with Jasper.
It's kind of just gone for it. You know, it's a very sort of like um,
how boy move to the scientific community.
I think they believe that I'm premature of not FDA approved and offering this to
the public. You don't know what it is. You don't know its purity.
It's not safe.
But I've talked to several clients who had really severe allergies and asthma.
They say they've just achieved these great results and desperate also says he
seen success with that with a few multiple sclerosis patients and several. Yeah,
crumbs. Do these patients too,
like how many people do you think that you have infected?
That's about 85 right now.
How is business isn't everything that doesn't necessarily is adequate,
but I honestly don't know why I don't wake up in the morning with my front
garden 20 deep with people with ulcerative colitis, Crohn's disease, allergies.
I just don't know why I'm not completely buried the way he sees it.
People are scared. Well,
they're the people who are coming from a point of view of what I learned in
kindergarten about clean drinking water and sewers to them.
Worms and parasites are so repulsive that there's nothing good to be said about
them, but I can make you better. It's simple. It's cheap.
I mean, for God's sake, these organisms fall out my rear end every day,
a half a million at a time.
The raw material is human excrement for God's sake.
All people have to do is open their minds.
You
are you really that scared of a little warm
[inaudible]
thanks to reporter Pat Walters and to a Jasper Lawrence into the worms and to
look them. Thank you. Hookworm. Thank you.
Hope more information about hookworms on our website and that's the end of this
section. [inaudible] the address radiolab.org yes.
Slash no,
it just not orange.
[inaudible]
Radiolab. We'll continue in a moment. This is Mike from Eldorado hills,
California.
Radiolab is supported in part by the National Science Foundation and by the
Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information about Sloan at www dot slow and that'll work.
Okay.
Hello, I'm Janna. Boom. Right. I'm Robert Krulwich, Radiolab. Today's topic,
parasites, where we have already learned that parasites can be good.
Sometimes Harris' sites can of course be very bad,
that also parasites can affect human behavior. Making this,
some of us a little lethargic or solving our real allergies.
Here's the question to consider though. Can they not just affect our behavior?
Can they control our behavior and different question in time? Yeah.
And you know, we were, we were thinking about this question, you know,
in the abstract doing some research,
but then things got kind of real when our producer Ellen Horn called in late to
work one day.
Hey Lulu. It's Alan. I'm just got home from the, that um,
I've been waiting on chest x rays, um, blood work from my cat,
Humana. Fast to me with, this is my cap notice.
Big lovely affectionate kitty. She's like the sweetest cat you will ever meet.
I've met Lewis, he's a very sweet kid. He's a darling,
but moose has a digestion problems.
And this one day I had to take her to the vet and as I was putting her into the
kitty carrier,
she managed the scratch me with her back claws and like a bloody wound on my
hand. Her back claws are like totally poop covered. So I'm kind of worried.
I have, I have six months pregnant.
The very first thing that they tell you when you get pregnant is stay away from
cat poop. So after it happened, I called my when by CC. Are you ready for me?
Yeah, she told me to rush right down to her office to apply pretty profusely.
It did. Wait a second. Why? What's so scary about cat poop? Well,
it turns out that cat poop can have in it this tiny parasite called Toxoplasma
Gondii. But what is the threat to the baby if it gets to the baby?
It can cause miscarriage.
It can cause stillbirth and it can also cause seizures, blindness.
So you're, you're, you're freaking out at this point. Yeah.
I'm kind of freaking out at this cranium small head.
My midwife said there's probably nothing to worry about. So she took my blood.
That's probably the better arm.
Can you say question and she sent me home.
The turnaround time for the test is between two and three days. Okay. Okay.
So I'm looking on the Internet at home.
I proceed to get myself even more freaked out.
A bunch of things about tax or plus markets.
One of the things that I found was this lecture by Robert Spolsky.
Okay. Example I'm talking about here.
He's a neuroscientist who we've had on the show
a lot. It has to do with a parasite called Toxoplasma.
And um, I just decided that I was going to call them up.
Hello and ask a few questions. Okay. So what's the deal with Toxo?
And he proceeded to tell me one of the most amazing feats of mind control that
I'd ever heard. What'd he tell you? Well,
the first thing he told me is that toxo doesn't actually want to
me and me. Yes, it really has wandered off into the wrong county.
If it winds up in a human,
it wants to be inside Mousse for totally mysterious reasons,
at least to me, talk so can only reproduce sexually in the gut of cats.
So it's there in mooses intestines that the toxoplasma meet and puck up.
Then they lay eggs.
Next Moose takes a trip to the backyard where she ichecks those eggs in her
pursue what's out there. Now when the cat feces,
step two says the Polski as that, you know,
maybe a week later a rat will come along and eat the cat poop.
Now toxo has a problem. It's stuck inside a rat.
It really wants to be inside a cat.
But rats totally freak out whenever they so much as even smell the cat. It's,
it's a hardwired aversion and talk.
Sue's evolutionary challenge has been to figure out how to get rodents inside
cat stomachs.
Here is where the mind control comes in and it's kind of hard to believe but
this is what [inaudible] says happens.
Toxo starts off in the stomach of the Roden,
takes about six weeks to migrate its way up to the brain and once it's in there
it finds this particular region called the Amygdala,
which is like command central for fear and anxiety and hair,
all of that.
It also finds this other region kind of right next door where a very different
emotion, less sexual arousal.
And what talks though seems to be able to do is to somehow
cross the wires. This may be some horrifically simplified soundbite,
but what I think is going on is the toxo knows how to make happier and smells
sexy. What to rodents, which that is so light,
bulk, totally bizarre,
but toxo makes rodents like the smell of cats and thus they approach and thus
they are more likely to wind up in the cat stomach. That's rough. Yeah.
In all other ways. The retina is totally normal, normal olfaction,
normal social behavior,
just hot for cats.
I start to wonder, well, this really likes the microphone. I love cats. Yeah.
Is it possible that toxo this is wonderful,
is what's been drawing me to cats. That's why we let her put her for everywhere.
I asked him pure speculation, but people who think about this stuff,
who view it as not just purely speculative to the notion that talks so can
produce some sort of attraction to cats and humans.
They don't think that's all that crazy.
Wait, so you're saying that like the crazy cat lady could be toxoplasma? Well,
no one's really studied that yet. Testing, testing,
but there are scientists out there that are making the case that talks. Oh,
can really change you. Okay.
Probably the most interesting established link is between Toxo and
schizophrenia. Dr Tare. Yup.
There's actually been the last count,
54 studies on Toxoplasma in people with schizophrenia and other psychosis.
That's Dr. Fuller Torrey.
He works at the Stanley Medical Research Institute that sponsors a lot of these
studies. Well,
I've been doing research on schizophrenia since the early seventies and he
thinks there's a link. Yeah, not a huge effect. The very,
very small risk of schizophrenia simply because schizophrenia is very rare.
But why would it cause schizophrenia to begin with?
Is it trying to cause schizophrenia?
Is that you imagine if the toxo was sort of lost in the brain.
If it thinks it's in a rat brain,
maybe it's just trying to do what it usually does to rats,
but in humans it has a very different effect. Nice.
And one of the reasons he thinks this might be true,
this connection between Toxoplasma and schizophrenia is because of a historical
length.
The fact that what we now call schizophrenia was quite rare until the late part
of the 18th century.
And then during the 18 hundreds schizophrenia increased very rapidly.
Why? This was the first time when we started to keep catches pets.
They first were adopted by the, um,
kind of east Greenwich village types in parish,
the artists, and it was really considered kind of weird,
but it's the kind of thing that if you were an artist or writer or something
like that,
you started to do a mini kind of spread the London where the writers and artists
kept it there. And then starting in about the 1840s,
he had started to become a little bit more popular.
And then in the 1860s and seventies, there was what called a cat.
Crazy cats were all over bleeding cards.
The first cat show was at London in 1870 and then Madison square garden I 1880.
It became very fashionable to have a cat,
we should say. I mean, he'll agree at this point it's just a theory. Okay.
But is there any evidence that toxo can actually control our behavior like it
does with the rats? Well,
there are some scientists out there who believe that toxo may affect something
more common to all [inaudible]
here's another one of those gimme a break. That's Robert Sapolsky. Again,
science fiction branches to the story to different groups independently have
seen people who are toxo infected have two to four times the likelihood of dying
in car accidents.
Really? Yeah. And I asked him why
insofar as toxo makes rodents get really imprudent about cat smells,
maybe toxo is making all sorts of mammals get imprudent about anything that
they're normally a skittish about like your body hurdling through space at a
high speed.
So in the end it might be possible,
might be possible that toxo is guiding our emotions
[inaudible]
changing who we are in some basic way.
And if you consider that toxo might just be one of thousands of tiny little
parasites inside us pulling our strings from the inside.
Well that thought is pretty creepy.
Even if the entire lesson with toxo is a small subset of infected people now
have one half of 1% more likelihood of one to drive really recklessly.
Um,
even lurking in that one half of 1% are some serious implications for thinking
about freewill.
We haven't a clue the biology lurking in the background.
That makes freewill seem a little bit suspect.
Either way. Whatever happened with your test about
this is me with my midwife,
Berry winter, my absence. She's giving me the news,
whatever we find out from the Toxo test that you have had past infection with
toxoplasma
positive,
you're positive. Yeah, but my midwife says that the baby's going to be okay.
The baby look like she's small. No, she looks like she's a nice size too.
A little bit on the larger size,
so not a baby I'd be worried about and I believe her.
Thanks, Helen. Sure.